all right while we are waiting
for our speaker to join us i just want
to let everyone know we're having a
little technical difficulty on that
front
but we will be starting as soon as he is
able to
join us so
my name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn and i'm
going to be
helping with the webinar today
ah here we go
hi kartik you're on mute
there we go i muted
hi i see
i hear you
sorry i was having some issues
i i first before we get started i have
to apologize to kartik um
for the technical difficulties we've
just been going through it's
really very frustrating sometimes when
these things happen but
i want everybody to know that
we had done a dry run and got this all
set up and
was
trying to log on several minutes before
the webinar started
just wasn't working through webex but
thank thankfully
it seems to be working now so
thank you kartik for being here and i'm
going to uh start the webinar
uh give me a moment to begin our live
stream
and we are now streaming to linkedin
live and youtube live
and i want to uh welcome kartik
ganapathi
and i want to welcome all of you as well
to our
webinar
so today's interview prep master classes
on how to ace data science interviews at
manufacturing companies
have with us cartagonipati who's an
analytics manager for ford motor company
and we're very fortunate to have him i
want to just do a quick note
before we get started we're going to ask
a couple of questions along the way and
we're going to let you ask questions as
well so
for those of you on the webex session
please answer your questions into the q
a panel
we will take a look at the chat messages
but
main place to put the questions for the
q a portion of the webinar later is in
the q a box
if you are on our live stream audience
uh please do put your questions in the
comments and
we have folks who will relay those
to uh kartik and me and
as i mentioned we'll be asking you a
couple of questions along the way the
first one now
is
basically how much work experience do
you have
we also
want to do a check and we've been doing
a check-in all throughout the pandemic
see how people are holding up as surges
come and go and how
isolation happens and
goes away
working remote is
sometimes stressful so
just doing the check-in as hopefully the
pandemic wanes
and here is the result
all right
kartik we have a
fairly experienced audience about 75
percent of folks are
more than two years of experience or you
know one or two years of experience on
up
but forty percent are
more than five years experience
we do have
a quarter of the audience however who
are still at university and will be out
looking for their
first jobs in the field soon
and by the way every
almost everybody is doing well or doing
okay so
glad to hear that
so
what i will do is i will um
stop sharing my screen and allow you to
share yours if you would like to do that
yeah uh
can you have this present um and can you
share this presentation i'm
logging in from a different
system
certainly i will
i will uh i will do the slides from here
yeah
okay and i'll let you um
speak a bit more about yourself as i
mentioned particularly is with ford
motor company and the professional
analytics manager so if you'd like to
tell us more about yourself
sure stuart thank you
uh
yeah good evening everyone good morning
good evening uh to everyone and uh first
of all i would like to apologize for any
uh for the delay uh
joining this call
so yeah so uh just getting to the
subject of uh
of how to ace data science interviews uh
before we start i just wanted to
say that there is a relation between
the topic
that we are discussing today as well as
uh my career so
i mean about 11 years back approximately
i
made a move into the analytics uh on the
data science industry
so again this was a mid-career shift and
i see that
almost more than 40 percent of the
audience here is more than five years
experience so i could see some relevance
there and i hope
some of what i on some of the tips i
provide here i hope that helps the
audience and helps them achieve their
dreams so yeah i have more than 17 years
of experience in
the
software development and analytics
consulting space
and i have worked across different
domains like banking automotive
marketing e-commerce
and yeah
currently i'm working as an analytics
manager at ford motor company
okay so uh
just getting into the topic of uh
what who are what are the types of data
science interview candidates so again i
have close to i said i have close to 11
years of experience in analytics i also
have close the same amount of experience
interviewing candidates
specifically in analytics and data
science
so broadly i would classify them as
into these categories right the freshers
you can assume them to be college
graduates it could be the engineering
graduates it could be
statistics it could be mba graduates uh
it could be experienced or laterals with
data science experience so again the
second one is what most companies are
you may know most companies are looking
for
uh people with say
two plus one plus two plus years
experience in data science
the other ones uh the third category i
would say is
people who move from other areas so this
is something i would like to address
today as well as i said
i have a similar background so i can
understand
understand what all it
takes and what is required from
recruiters perspective for a candidate
to clear an interview right so
if there are any questions i would like
to address that
and the last one is highly experienced
people again
i am
specifically naming
this as a separate category 10 or 15
plus years so this includes both
experienced as well as people who do not
have experience in data science uh the
reason i'm putting this separately is
the recruiter's perspective will change
based on the experience of the candidate
that's something i have seen and again
there are different combinations that
could come up so yeah
these are the four categories i would
broadly classify into so hopefully
i address some of what
the categories that we see who are there
in the audience
yeah so going to uh
what do what does a typical data science
interview look like
uh so again this is a broad
classification when we could go into my
new details but i have tried to classify
broadly
we have interviewed
people from campus
like we call them college graduates or
it could be like i said mba engineering
graduates
uh so one one advice is be very good on
your academic subjects uh
uh
maybe you could go back to the yeah
yeah one address is be very good on your
academic subjects ensure that
if for example let's take you
are a computer science engineer ensure
that
you are well versed in
the key topics like
programming or be it rdb the database
management and so on so ensure that
you're well versed in it and i'm sure
these days in
most of the courses everything from
mba to engineering they have analytics
data science as one of the subjects
so uh try to brush up on those subjects
as well just come up to speed on that
another thing is critical thinking uh
again fresh college graduates they are
uh mostly they do not have experience
prior experience
dealing with
dealing with customers or business
end business
so i would say develop critical thinking
when i say critical thinking is
having a complete view on
a 360 degree holistic view of a problem
rather than
you know just pigeonhole yourself into a
specific
solution right so
that needs a lot of ground to be covered
i can possibly cover that in the
following slides
right and last and i would say one of
the very important ones is start with
side projects so college graduates
freshers they do not have any other
experience to show so it could either be
their internships it could either be
their academic projects
or it could be their site projects so by
site products i mean something you could
build an application and host it on
a lot of free hosting services
again i can give some details on that i
have some slides on that so this uh i
can tell you it this can really
impress the recruiter
because
in the end
clearing a course or
getting a certificate can be done maybe
we would give it a 20 weightage but if
we see a real application that's been
deployed let's say an nlp application or
a computer vision application you have
deployed it say on a platform like
heroku or gcp and you have put it out
like a portfolio for people to see and
they will be really impressed looking at
that and if you can more than that if
you can able to talk through your
solution go through those details i
think i can assure you people will be
really
uh impressed by that
so
yeah going on to the next categories the
experienced folks uh
uh again uh this covers both
people with data science as well as well
as people without data science
background
so with data science i would say it's
relatively easier because you have
past projects to talk about data science
projects to talk about so again pick the
key ones here but i assume
again we did not do a survey but i
assume that most of the people here may
not have prior working experience they
may have
experience in other
industries like they may have been
working in i.t and would want to move to
this field right so
so
in that case i would say
ensure that you upskill of course
of course knowing uh the the data
science techniques the
the nitty gritties is important but also
develop an understanding of the industry
you're trying to get to so in this case
if it's manufacturing
ensure you understand get a
understanding of the domain
uh because that plays a major part as
well right
also if you don't have any background
experience in data science earlier
uh
one one thing i could suggest is uh
you you would have seen recently
there is this talk of what is called the
great uh resignation right so you would
have seen companies serve i.t services
companies product companies their
attrition rates are topping uh
like 15-20 percent right even more than
that uh and that is because companies
really need this talent everything from
i t to data science again data science
is just one part of it there is a lot
more skills required by companies and
what i mentioned here like
skills and deployment devops cloud so
you would have known that this is not
very specific to data science but uh
offlate this is becoming a skill that
people in this industry would also like
to have right
the recruiters would like to see
candidates with this experience
uh it's it's definitely a plus
so if you have such a experience but
have not worked specifically on data
science i would say
you could
highlight this as one of the areas
also if you have domain expertise for
example you have
worked in say sales or marketing and you
have worked maybe as a business analyst
but you have worked in a manufacturing
for a manufacturing company their domain
knowledge again can come useful so
there are multiple angles here which a
recruiter will look at and like i said
uh there is a lot of demand currently
for uh for talent
and because there is a crunch people are
also trying to compromise on what they
are looking for so
when i say compromise it is something
like
if you do not have say a machine
learning
project
already
it's still okay as long as you are good
in say other areas like the domain
skills as well as your communication and
other soft skills
yeah so moving on to the next one uh
so key topics to prepare
so uh again uh the student the people
here we are all they're all
uh i i believe you are all completing a
course at simply learn and uh you would
have gone through an extensive uh
syllabus uh done a lot of assignments
so one thing i would advise is whoever
has done this course ensure that
you are well versed with all the models
and algorithms so take for example a
random forest algorithm right
if you go to an interview one of the
questions could be can you walk me
through
a random forest algorithm how that works
uh how do you how do you improve the
model if if you are building a random
random forest
model right or how do you
how do you describe xgboost model and
how does that differ from a random
forest model or
bert is a nlp
nlp model
again there are a lot more nlp models
that i use so whatever you learnt
whatever you put on your resume as you
may just ensure that
you are
you are well versed in that
other kind of topics they ask is case
studies and
scenarios so this is
uh
again for people with experience this is
something that can definitely come up so
to give a very simply uh let's say a
manufacturing company they can give you
a supply chain related case study
and say that how will you solve how do
you optimize for the inventory right it
would be a very open problem statement
and you may need to think through
uh what all entities are there what all
assumptions you need to make
and
what all assumptions you need to make
and you need to state that explicitly
and then say what kind of techniques you
would do so possibly you could use an
optimization technique to
uh for a supply chain problem uh so
that's something that you need to think
through
there are scenarios that would be given
and you would be required to solve that
right
uh
so that's what
again i have spoken to a few of my
colleagues
as well i have spoken to few other
people who are in manufacturing domain
uh just to understand what's their point
of view and this is something that's
common across right they
while
while understanding the algorithm uh
being well-versed in it trying having
the coding programming skills is
definitely good
uh what they want is uh thinking in
terms of business and the data that will
be required
right so uh yeah so that's something
that i would request you to uh you all
to focus on as well
uh case studies you can find a lot of
them online on internet uh you could
even look at say uh things like how how
do popular companies stop companies how
do they use machine learning for solving
their use cases right it's all there on
the internet so you could
look at that
and then uh
yeah the other one is uh like i said the
data oriented thought process so they
would like to know if i uh if i
give you a problem in
in this domain right like i said supply
chain bit supply chain or marketing
right uh this is the problem statement
what all data elements do you think you
need
again it's a very open statement so have
a holistic approach to whatever how you
solve it
so some of the examples i have given
here how would you build a product to
optimize inventory how do you improve
driver safety right
to just give an example
when
can a driver goes off when he is driving
so can you monitor that and uh and maybe
send a warning alarm uh just to ensure
that uh
that incident doesn't occur
that's just a couple of examples i could
give
and similarly another area is ensure
that you you may have worked you may
have five years ten years experience
ensure that you look back and think say
think of say two to three or four key
projects that you think
can really
add value to uh during your interview
process
no inside out of that particular those
projects again this may involve
specifically data science projects as
well as say non-data science so if they
want to understand your devops skills uh
what kind of projects have you done in
the past related to devops right can you
give details and specifically also on
the business side what kind of benefits
what was the situation what challenges
did you face
how big was your team
and how did you coordinate among
different team members right so these
are questions that would typically come
up so yeah i would say always ensure you
have a bag of about
if you are relatively new maybe you may
have lesser number of projects but if
you are experienced like 5-10 years
you should have at least three to four
good projects that you should be able to
cover which the interviewer would ask
yeah so interviews do's and don'ts again
this is purely compiled based on my
experience i have seen
some of this
so again this is uh just an advice for
people uh either to avoid or to follow
some of what i'm stating here
so first thing of course do not ramble
so
some of
the interview candidates have seen
uh go completely off topic as you may
know
it could be either they don't understand
the question
or uh they do not know what the answer
is right so in that case they just start
trampling so avoid that kind of a
situation be
to the point
because that the interviewer may lose
interest if you do that
right
the other thing is think of the business
problem again like i said in the end
data science is to solve specific
problems in the industry
uh and again view
it's it's an enabler it's it's it
enables us to cut down on a lot of uh
like unnecessary tasks improve
productivity improve revenue reduce cost
so you should think in terms of
the
business
be it e-commerce be it manufacturing be
it marketing sales
banking any of this industry you should
be very specific on what if they give
you a problem how do you solve it right
sometimes i see people think of
like a fancy or a fancy ml
solution like they say i will use an nlp
to solve this or i will use clustering
algorithms to solve this whereas
that may not even be required there may
be simpler solutions
yeah and
yeah the next one is
ensure you understand the question i
think i covered this earlier like do not
ramble
uh ensure you are to the point uh else
the interviewer may lose attention and
uh you know that's a sure sign that he
may reject you so avoid uh avoid
rambling ensure you are to the point
and the other one is uh yeah this is an
important one customize yourself to the
interview right
uh
again
a plain vanilla approach like
broadcasting your resume to 100
companies and
hoping the same kind of interview may
not be as effective
i know that is easier and much less time
consuming but believe me if you go spend
that extra time maybe it may take an
hour more if you are interviewing for
say a specific company x or y
ensure that you customize yourself to
that specific company so if you are
interviewing for a company
ensure you understand what is the role
right uh what is the role and what kind
of skills do they require and this may
be the
recruiter will tell you during the
initial call that they would have done
even before she during the interview so
sometimes i see people coming to
interviews and
asking like can i know more about the
role which is
which maybe they did not get that
information or maybe they did not go
through
the job description right it could be
any one of them
or the other is they are not clear
between the type of role requirements so
like i said there are different roles in
data science uh anything from say a ml
engineer a data engineer
to a deployment mlops
right all of these are different roles
with different uh
skill sets required that some of it may
be overlapping so ensure you go through
the jd and customize yourself to the
interview uh
like it's worth the time that spent
on that
and of course be formal and have a very
pleasant demeanor sometimes uh
you not
uh paying attention or you being very
casual it may give a signal that ah
people are not interested right again
there's something i have noticed in
interviews
yeah
can you move to the next level yeah
so yeah so again uh
so again uh
in terms of research uh there are fewer
areas i wanted to cover the first is
market trends and data science again
ensure you
while working on why even if you are
working on your projects you are
fully into it
ensure that you are
you are in touch with ground reality
what are the kinds of uh
changes that are happening around you so
there are a lot of good journals
like some of them i have uh
i have included here like analytics
india mag or there could be
like kd nuggets which all this
consolidate the kind of uh
the kind of developments that are
happening in this field uh simply learn
or any of these other online
online
training institute so i've seen a lot of
videos from simply learn as well as
other institutes and believe me it's
free so you just have to spend time to
learn it right it's all free and it's
there on youtube and again a few more
resources i can
show you in the next few slides so what
i'm saying is ensure you are aware of
what are the trends in data science
again this would maybe apply more
maybe for the freshers uh people who are
graduating say engineering or
mbas it may be the questions may be a
little more complex but
freshers uh one thing they would like to
know is if you are interested can you
tell me what are the trends in this
domain right in data science and i have
seen people when not really being able
to say uh
even basic things so
that's why i'm suggesting you go through
these kind of resources
yeah
and the other research is about the
company and the job profile so
again as
the topic of this webinar it's about
interviews at manufacturing companies so
again this applies for any company
most importantly like i said spend that
extra time going through the company
websites it could be their annual
reports or any interviews by their cxos
or any industry trends right uh just go
through them and
have a point of view on them like do you
think this going where do you think this
is heading towards like in the
automobile industry you have
the electric vehicles that are coming
along so where do you think this is
being headed which companies are getting
affected
uh there was a chip shortage problem
sometime
that's shortage problem so uh how do you
think that is affecting and who all are
really getting affected right so
these are some things that you can even
look out of curiosity
again this kind of questions can come
for freshers not necessarily experienced
people
but
company research i would suggest
irrespective of whatever
experience you are in i would say
research about the company read about
the company
what's happening what is how it's doing
and any be ready with at least
three to four questions right this will
help you ask them like
why are certain things happening in that
particular company why is your revenue
down and why was your stock down
recently or what kind of strategy are
you planning to in the next quarter
right so
have questions specific to that company
again
i have seen people not
ask questions they just
most of them do ask but
either the questions are not of
are very
shallow or they just say we do not have
questions which may not give a good
impression
if you want to show that you are
interested you need to ask questions
about the company more details about the
role about the working culture right you
should show that you are interested in
that particular role
yeah
yeah can move to the next slide
okay so
again this is something again i put this
purely based on my experience i did not
uh i did not do any uh research maybe i
may be wrong i may be correct
so there are some things i have noticed
that can go in your favor
or it may go against you
again
experience level so
this is a very subjective
line so i would say please don't uh
don't
take it take it with a grain of salt
so don't think that people with
experience do not have a chance like i
said i was close to six to seven years i
had close to six to seven years
experience and when i moved to this
industry i uh i was not in a technical
role i was more a business analyst and
more functional role
uh but one thing i have noticed is
people with low experience level say one
year in an iit industry or a two-year in
a it industry you want to shift uh you
may be preferred again there are
different reasons for that you may be
able to learn
uh quickly so
there are different reasons for that
for experienced personal this is
a question that people have asked
earlier
again this could be
anything from say 5 to 10 plus 15 plus
years experience i have seen
people taking internal rotations within
your company so
uh this is a good option provided your
company has
has a policy of rotation i know
uh company some companies they
allow for internal rotation from one
division to another
so if you are working in say the
marketing department you want to move to
the analytics department
you could speak to your supervisor and
possibly get an internal rotation right
again this may not apply to all
companies some companies may not have a
mature
analytics group but yeah this is
something i would suggest you always
look out for
the other one is
look for contacts connect over linkedin
so by contacts i mean even your
people you know personally uh or people
who are in your alumni group or
your friends relatives anything like
that right uh
just a post on something like a whatsapp
group
saying so-and-so needs uh is having an
experience of uh two years or five years
and he's looking for a role in data
science uh these kinds of things do work
uh
you can you have a chance of getting
a call
again
it all depends on the type of companies
if it's
a large company with an established
process the hr may have their own
process
in that case
they may not be able to take you in but
if it's like something like that's where
i say
look at some things like startups right
this again is something i have seen
i have worked at uh relatively smaller
sized companies and
i've seen that people without
data science experience say
three to five years they join us say
interns or they join us
they join as data scientists
and but once they get even
a year's experience they
they become like experienced candidates
data science candidates and i have seen
them move into
other companies do very well post that
so
again i say target startups not
it's a very broad statement it can even
be
target uh
companies which do not have a very
specific hr process right so all this
you can do through your contacts
uh so again you could ask for an
internship if you are
if you are a fresh college graduate you
can look for a internship
or like i said you could move through
your circles to get any job
opportunities
so yeah linkedin is definitely a very
good resource please
do make your good use of it messaging
people
personally messaging people
and explaining to them about your
interest i think that works quite well
so
be on the lookout on linkedin as well
another thing i think in the previous
slide was
meetups so
i have been part of something called as
meetups local meetups
uh facebook groups linkedin groups
especially facebook groups
so there are some serious
this again this i'm not assuring that it
will work but there is a chance that you
could find
a founder a startup founder or a
co-founder
and you may happen to meet and you could
introduce yourself you could express
interest i have seen i have attended
such groups and i even know a few people
who i refer to and uh got placed there
so again this is a
a good option if you have time to spend
like on weekends if you could attend
such meetups or at least be active
on such platforms i think that's a good
chance to get interview calls as well
yeah
so uh
next slide please
yeah so again these are a few resources
again it's not an extensive one but
but again whatever i could
i have mostly gone through whatever i
have seen and something which i refer to
again there are a ton of resources like
i said simply youtube you could just go
to youtube you could say free code camp
and learn a specific topic and
uh
like you will have that right similarly
blogs towards data science.com is a blog
just specifically for data science
hacker rank again
like a competitive programmer if you
could uh write code here you you will be
given points specifically you will be
given badges and that would be again
like uh accomplishment that you can show
right rather than talk and introduce
that you are interested in data science
you can show them that hacker rank is
recognized across the industry
and yeah the books uh i would say this
is something i'm reading currently
skillet killed by
and it's very optional uh
something i liked because
he very specifically addresses uh
what kind of challenges that uh
professional face
in today's world fast changing world
what kind of skills are required and
specifically it talks a lot about soft
skills so again if you have time you can
go through that
yeah so
yeah i'm open for any questions
right and we have a number of questions
that have come in from the audience and
i'm going to
take the slide off the screen and let us
talk um
so
let me start with um
a general question that applies to a
number of people we're
coming from a
non-computing background some people
coming from mechanical engineering
some from non-technical degree programs
that type of thing
so
what would your advice carthag be
to people
from those backgrounds who are
interested in pivoting into data science
okay so
again uh
i assume you are referring to say
experienced candidates with
a
non-technical background is that
yeah somebody who's been working for
example one of the one of prakash has
asked and he's got five plus years of
working in a mechanical background
but not i.t so how would you how would
you advise somebody like him
sure
i think one way
a couple of things i would suggest
like i said internal rotation
is one of them
because
if you have an internal analytics team
that's definitely you can consider
the other positive i could see is the
domain knowledge which again is a key in
this field so while you have uh
different
models algorithms platforms coming up
domain knowledge is the key because and
then businesses are asking about
the kind of impact that your solution
has right and for that you need deep
domain knowledge and from what you said
like mechanical or beat any field
these have require a good amount of
domain knowledge so say automotive
or other manufacturing industries it
needs good domain knowledge
so because you have worked in that field
you will have a very good idea of what
kind of data
would be required broadly and that in
turn can
definitely compensate for maybe your
for the
lack of the technical skills that you
have and
again i would say develop some basic
skills
like sql python
coding and that will be like a
compliment so it will be like a
combination you can think of you have
very good domain knowledge plus a
a decent knowledge of a few other skills
you may not be very good but if you're
very good domain knowledge your
communication is good and the right
approach i think people will definitely
consider
i think we're related to that we have a
question from a linkedin
viewer
persona asks
i have a varied background in
manufacturing
supply chain management marketing
business operations
experience with oracle database in
delphi
sap tools
data science certificate so
with a person with a
varied background of that type
how would they position themselves
in a data science interview
yeah so again you mentioned a couple of
technical areas uh like sap
uh
or a few other areas that you mentioned
along with the specific domains you
mentioned marketing
and manufacturing so
again depends on the type of experience
for example i fall into a similar
bracket i don't know how much experience
this person is so i have close to 17
years and if you see i almost have
worked in five to six different
industries
uh
so yeah you could pick one such industry
in which you are really good at say
manufacturing like i said earlier or
marketing and with that domain knowledge
plus i heard there were a few other
technical skills you mentioned i think
those should be a good uh
start for you like i said you go through
your personal contacts
again
large companies they have a fixed
process the hr has a fixed process of
hiring laterals who fit into a category
uh or they go to specific campuses right
so
going through contacts going
targeting startups or smaller companies
is
one of your good bets
um speaking of domain knowledge and deep
domain knowledge um prashanth
asked
got 10 years of working in the
automobile
domain
and
would like to move into data science
so
his
is his best bet
focusing in on opportunities in the
automobile industry or
does he would another strategy work
better for him
well 10 years in the automobile industry
i would say definitely you could
focus on that
again like i said there are different
options if yours is a large company you
can look for a rotation
but at the same time also develop the
technical skills like i said when people
look at a combination deep domain
expertise is definitely something that
will help
though there are companies that you may
need to target to that is one
disadvantage but the good news is
domain knowledge is really valued so
that coupled with your technical skills
if you could uh just brush up on that
even if you are average but you can make
up with the
domain knowledge i think
that would be your best bet
and again like i said earlier you to get
a toe hold into
data science you just need that say the
first year working on data science
projects and post that it will be like
you will be almost like you will be part
of the data science professional group
right and you could even change the
domain from automotive to something else
sure
um
from another uh
user
ish
chat
takes a look at the other end of the of
the spectrum where a person's a fresher
non-technical background but has taken a
course in data science
and
what are the steps a person like that
should take
to be able to
interview confidently for a data science
job you've gone i think
extensively into some of those during
your presentation about the the type of
research people should do the type of
projects people should do could you
could you kind of give a
summary recap of that
sure so i would like you said i would
cover a few tips specifically for
freshers
first i assume you would
get an interview call maybe either
through your contacts or
through linkedin so once you get that
call
again let's assume you are in the
interview there are few things like i
said before
a few
basic mistakes i have seen
freshers make and
that is either not having an idea about
the role
also about the domain right so you said
you have a non-technical background i
can
understand that you have done a
certification of course
so use that as an opportunity to
build something and put it out there
i'm not sure if i i i don't know if i
missed a slide but uh there are
platforms free platforms i can name it
uh you can just google and see so that
is something called heroku that is
uh gcp provides a one year gcp is google
cloud platform
so you can
build a solution and deploy it on
the cloud
so they give a 300 credit for one year
but again once that expires in one year
you will be charged on a credit card but
so these are free platforms where you
could uh host your applications
streamlit is one more they have a cloud
cloud platform where you could deploy
your applications tableau if you are
looking to become a visualization expert
you could create visualization and put
it on uh the tableau platform again this
will be out for everyone to see right so
what i'm trying to say is as a fresher
you're sending the message that i am
really keen on this and it's not that
i'm just stopping at uh at the theory
level i have implemented this and i know
quite a bit about so it's almost like
you are six months you can call yourself
like six months experience with this
kind of
projects right and i have i have been
like i said the other end of uh spectrum
i have seen candidates who are
who have amazed me with the kind of
knowledge even though they were freshers
during campus interviews they the kind
of knowledge they had they were able to
explain even though theoretical they
were able to explain some of these
models and algorithms so i mean they are
definitely a pick
also given focus on the communication
part
ensure you
brush up on the soft skills and
definitely about the company customize
yourself to the company and the dom
okay
uh
from our linkedin audience shubham uh
says
i'm a self-taught python developer
um what additional
skills or or preparation should i do
get into data science or is being a
python developer
enough to start me off
again a python developer i assume you
are saying something not related to data
science
so you could pick an area where you want
to specialize in again
machine learning could be
something that you could start with
like i said you said self-taught but i
don't know whether you are experienced
or how much experience
so again depending on that i would say
pick a area so
the word of caution here is this field
data science field is really vast the
kind of knowledge that's required
and the kind of roles the specific kind
of roles that's created is
there are quite a number of them so try
to understand the roles and if you're a
python developer try to understand where
will where will you want to fit in right
do you want to be ml engineer do you
want to be a ml ops which is more into
deployment do you want to be a cloud
engineer so all these are different
options uh or do you want to get into
visualization
right so all these are different options
so think of what role you need and up
skill yourself in that particular area
so each of this will need
focus on specific areas
so yeah just ensure you understand what
are the roles out there and what kind of
role you would like yourself to be in
okay
we have a question let me see if i look
at it uh
ramadan johnny
who asks
i'm a computer science engineer with a
career break of 10 years
i want to restart my career in data
science
how would
you suggest he proceeds
okay so
again this is a tough question because
like you said a career break of 10 years
frankly is uh
quite uh
i don't know it's
uh there are return to work kind of for
women that has returned to work i mean i
may be deviating from the topic but
there there are rules where people have
an option return to work companies these
days are providing an option
for
women to get back
into a career
and
so that could be a good option a lot of
companies are doing that so again
specific to
specific to women i think
if that if you have taken a career break
then that's a very good option right
currently there are a lot of companies
providing such opportunities to women
who want to get back
to the corporate world so that could be
one
again i don't know what was your
experience before
you took the break
but yeah again internships could be one
you could look for internships and
try to get
placed in that same place again like i
said
look for companies which do not have a
very rigid hiring process
so uh like try to reach out to
recruiters try to reach out through your
contacts
uh there are tons of startups uh you may
not even have heard of them
uh anything from say bangalore hyderabad
uh delhi mumbai there are tons of
startups working and they may need at
least a intern who they want to help
them right there may be tasks and they
want an intern whom they can whose help
they can use
so again that's something that uh you
can look at
uh we also have a question from kinzhal
who
six years work experience as a software
developer
and have having trouble convincing
employers that he wants to
pivot to data science so
it says whenever
i apply for a job
i wasn't shortlisted as a data scientist
i was shortlisted
as a developer so
um
how can
kingshill
emphasize that
yes i want to
move out of development into data
science
okay again
this is very role specific so
like i said if there are careers there
are job sites career sites for each
company
and i presume that you are looking at
the job opportunities the openings that
are
provided there and
accordingly you are applying for those
roles right
a software developer with six years
experience like i said
uh
again the experience is a little on the
higher side
uh but again depends on what kind of
software developer
experience you had if you have worked
with sql or if you have worked with
cloud platforms that that could be
something of a talking point you could
use
uh like i said uh you could just look up
the type of roles
there in these in this field uh ml ops
is like a like a derivative of devops
right for machine learning how to deploy
machine learning algorithms so let's say
you are you have been an id for six
years you have been in devops envelopes
could be uh something that you can be
considered right
again the same things that i said
earlier you could
you could customize your profile ensure
you write a cover letter specifically
covering that what would appeal to
the recruiter right some people may not
even require such kind of skills they
may not need a devops skills they may
need a pure
machine learning engineer kind of role
so you need to look at that you need to
customize your profile your cover letter
and
look at what kind of companies you
target
and we have someone from the youtube
chat who
says that they recently completed
completed
their degree and then pursued a data
science course
but haven't been able to find any job
opportunities data science and they're
in india so
can you give them some idea of things
they might change that would help them
reposition themselves and make
themselves more attractive
okay so
did this person say that
they are fresher or
or
they have prior work experience
my impression is that they're refresher
that they recently graduated
and after that did a data science course
but it doesn't talk about their work
experience so
um let's assume that refresher
okay so again like whatever i said
earlier i think that applies here if
you're a fresher i understand uh i
understand uh that not getting
a call or not getting a
interview opportunity i think that can
be
a bit disheartening
but yeah like there are other avenues
you can look at like i said always
be good on your subjects and ensure you
see what companies you are targeting
right uh
if something is not working take a real
re-look at yourself uh see are you
looking at all applying to all the big
companies which require experienced
people in that case you may not
check the box right whereas look for
something out of the box something like
an internship again like
repeating what i said earlier you could
go through your contacts uh you could
spread the word around again there are
facebook groups whatsapp groups uh if
you just float your resume along with
the kind of projects and one more thing
i wanted to add was a github profile
this something i missed
but
for people for freshers i think that's
a must in today's day
like i said
theoretical knowledge is one whatever
you put on your resume but if you want
to have the differentiation one is uh
you need to show the practical work you
have done the deployments the
applications you have developed
uh and put it out there say deploy it on
a cloud platform right and have a github
profile
be active on github and
upload whatever work you do there as a
fresher i would say that would be a good
differentiator even for experience and
especially for refreshers i would
suggest that's a good option
and likewise i said
please also
try to change your
the kind of type of companies you are
applying for look for smaller companies
and
try to move through your contacts
okay
um
we have an interesting question uh
kind of
a little bit on the side but
i think it's an interesting question
uh pranav in our linkedin audience
is working on a project called deep
learning for crop classification using
satellite imagery precision agriculture
a fascinating field
and
so he's asking if anybody knows about
agriculture company using artificial
intelligence
um
developing those kinds of
new tools and systems
okay i am not able to
i'm not able to immediately recall at
the top of my mind but
uh i did come across one company i'm
unfortunate not able to recollect it
i have left my contact
my email id if you could just
mail me on there i can definitely get
back to you on the companies i did have
at least a couple of them
i can get do some research and get you a
few more but yeah do drop me an email i
can respond back on it
i think we have a related question from
uh amman
who
has a phd in plant sciences
and has taken an eight year break
as a mom of two kids raise her children
now she wants to get back to work and as
she said their programs
for that type of thing um but
she's curious to know because she's done
one of the
data science programs through simply
learn
her question is what else can she do
after that
program to gain more confidence in a
completely new field
so i think you had talked about all the
tools that are or techniques people can
use in terms of doing projects um
open source projects uh
doing more independent study of the
trends in the industry and that type of
thing except
pretty much going back to
what you presented uh today and
yeah so again since uh this person said
uh
like she took a break and uh like she's
done a phd
uh again i'm not
sure
the area that she's done that but
uh she said plant sciences so it's also
agriculture related
okay okay so uh yeah phd's uh again if
uh you could look at specific domains uh
for this
uh
look at companies that you can target
that applies to the uh the kind of
area you have taken up in your phd i
think uh that can be a good bet
and
yeah like i said earlier uh
phds are
are preferred in this area as well there
are specific technical
uh
technical areas that phds fill in and
data science so that's something that
you can look at
yeah
and
we're reaching
our time so i'm going to
apologize to everyone whose questions we
couldn't answer live
but as uh
kartik has mentioned he has
graciously shared his contact
information and i'm going to get to that
in a moment i'll put that into the chat
right now while we're getting ready to
talk about something else
here are his email and linkedin
contact points
put that into the chat so you have that
available
i want to mention a program that
stimulator offers in india specifically
called the full
sorry on full stack it should be data
science java
data science
with the job guarantee i am looking at
this
got the wrong program listed here but we
do have a program in data science
that comes with a job guarantee the job
guarantee
because we know as
kartika identified there's a lot of
companies
who
just need talent
and a number of them have committed to
simply learn that they can pretty much
hire as many people as we can train so
it's a six month type program it goes
uh in a step-by-step
uh
series of courses and of course i've got
the wrong set of courses up here this is
the software development but
what you end up with is a certificate
that certifies that you've completed the
data science program
you end up with a number of projects
including a capstone project that you
have in your portfolio that you can
demonstrate to potential employers
and
ultimately with this particular program
and in india only
if you complete the program
successfully
and follow the
career assistance steps that we provide
for you
guarantee that one of our partner
employment companies will give you a
bonafide job offer in writing within six
months or you'll get your fees refunded
i know that that might be of interest to
people who are
making a transition or pressure in the
field
um
and i'd just like to ask the question
having embarrassed myself by putting up
the wrong
course information but i do want to ask
uh
based on what i've just told you
is this something you might be
interested in
let me give you a few seconds to answer
that
and if it is is this something that
you'd like to do right away or do would
you like to
think about doing it
more into the future
i'll share with you the result
and
almost three-quarters of the audience
are interested in the program of this
type
and about
40 percent want to do it um
within the next three months so
what i'm going to share in the chat
again is a
link to the program page for the correct
program pretty sure
and um i will also
include an email address that you can
use to contact
simply learn about this
program
so that's in the chat here you've got
the program page and also an email
address you can use to contact us to
find out more about that program
with that again i will drop kartik's
information in the chat
just to be sure
i want to thank um
kartik for being here and
being so generous with his time and with
his knowledge
um
really appreciate that kartik thank you
yeah thank you thank you stuart for
having me here on this webinar and
thanks a lot uh to the audience here i
hope uh i answered some of your
questions and clarified some of your
doubts and all the best for your career
we will be sharing a follow-up email
with uh everyone in the the audience
here
um yeah
which includes a
link to the recording of this
presentation so
you'll be able to review the information
that kartik shared
misspelled your name as cathy i
apologize for that
um
but
i will share that in the follow-up email
so that you can review the resources
that
he's talked about in his advice
and our next
career master class is next week on
thursday which is a
another interviewing
master class this one is about software
development
we're very fortunate in that case to
have
uh avital aurora who is a
director of engineering at google and
she'll be able to share with you
if you're in software development or if
you know people who are and would like
to share this information with them
please
do send them
this link and i put it in the chat that
they can register for this
interview prep
webinar next week and hear from somebody
who's working at one of the
premier fang companies in the world so
with that i'm going to thank
everybody in the audience for being here
and remind you you can follow us on our
social media channels that simply learn
on facebook
ask simply learn on twitter
and simply learn on linkedin
we'd love to
have you keep in touch with us we'd love
to welcome you into the simply learned
learning community
and
either way we want to wish all of you
every success in your data science
career so
thank you for being here and that
concludes
today's webinar
you